I've decided to keep a journal to set
down all my thoughts and a simple
offense of my day I will keep this diary
for one year and at the end of that time
it will be destroyed
I encourage my son to enlist it was a
family tradition six months later he was
dead in Iraq I was lost lessons the
reading of the Lord praise begun
[Music]
so who are you I'm fine no really it's
been a while since we've talked even a
pastor needs bastard did you see the
doctor you need someone to take care of
you I want you to be happy
I know that nothing can change and I
know there is no hope yes marry
explosives she was becoming someone I
didn't know
opportunistic diseases and our key
martial law you will live to see this
you had no idea what he was thinking no
I'm so frightened these kids they lost
certainty you know don't think follow
they fall prey to extremism it's world
without hope no I have not lost my face
you think what we did together was a
synth I've seen enough real sin to know
the difference you didn't tell it please
take a look at your own life before you
criticize others
these are frightening times we have to
be patient well somebody has to do
something
in the sole frenzied blood
Oh
[Music]
spotless
my hands shake as I write these lines
can God forgive us for what we've done
to this world who can know the mind of
God
you